welcome to pymol 101 with molecular
memory KP here I've done some longer
free-form Primal tutorials in the past
but in this series I'll take you through
shorter targeted lessons so it'll be
easy to get started and find the exact
videos you need let's begin with basic
operation of the Primal 2 graphical user
interface or GUI
I'm using pymol 2.4.2
if you're using another version you
might notice differences
feel free to drop your version number
and observations in the comments to help
out other Learners we're going to load a
structure of hemoglobin from the protein
Data Bank
let's check it out at the rcsb pdb first
navigate to
rcsb.org and type
4mqk in the search bar
on the page that comes up notice the
four differently colored parts
hemoglobin is a tetramer a protein made
up of four separate chains to load the
biological assembly of hemoglobin and
pymol click the drop down file menu and
select get pdb
Type 4 mqk in the pdb ID box
now very important type the number one
into assembly click download and the
structure pops up in the structure
viewer window we'll have a whole episode
on coloring but for now click on color
the C button here in the names panel
choose by chain and select the Top
Choice
notice the four uniquely colored chains
a faster way to load structures is to
use the command line where you can
execute actions with typed codes
type fetch followed by the four digit
alphanumeric pdb ID
but when we do this with 4mqk we see
eight chains without getting too deep
the fetch command by itself loads the
structure in a way that's related to
crystal structure symmetry which will
sometimes show extra stuff and sometimes
display half a protein
if you really want to use the command
line to load structures I'll show a
longer code on screen that'll load the
biological assembly
I learned this from the pie mole Wiki
your One-Stop shop for powerful command
line codes that'll help you do lots of
cool stuff with pymol okay main
takeaways
use get pdb in the file menu to load
structures and set the assembly to one
compare your structure to the image in
the rcsb pdb to make sure it loads as
expected
and visit the Primal Wiki to learn
command line codes
now the whole point of using a structure
viewer like pymol is to get a sense of
the molecule in three dimensions
now Primal used to pretty much require a
mouse and you may still prefer to use
one
but updates to the GUI have made it
really easy to use pymol with a trackpad
and that's what all show in this
tutorial
rotate is left click and drag
so I'm just clicking and dragging on my
trackpad to rotate here
Zoom is right click so clicking and
running two fingers up and down the
track pad Zooms in and out
more conveniently the pinch and spread
motion also zooms
sometimes we'll want to move the whole
structure to reposition it this is a
trackpad keyboard combo
on my Mac I can click either command or
option
and then click and drag using the
trackpad and this translates the whole
molecule
to re-center click the action button the
little a here in the names panel and
select Center
the first thing I do after loading a
structure is show the sequence in the
drop down menu select display sequence
the sequence pops up giving the one
letter codes for the amino acids that
make up the primary structure of the
protein
this gray bar here is a scroll bar
let's look at the whole sequence by
clicking and dragging on it
following the first chain we find a
string of O's the oxygen atoms in water
molecules which show up as red dots in
the structure viewer here
continue scrolling and we find chain B
notice it's colored the same as in the
structure below making it easy to
identify
if we scroll further we'll see some
unique three-letter codes
hem is the he molecule that shows up in
a stick representation in the structure
viewer below
heme enables hemoglobin to bind oxygen
we can select one of the hems by
clicking on it in the sequence here
or on the structure itself in the
structure viewer
there's also CMO
these are carbon monoxide molecules
bound to the oxygen binding site
they're smaller so they're hard to see
let's use Primal to focus in on one
click on a CMO in the sequence
the letters s-e-l-e pop up in the names
panel here and this selection
corresponds to whatever we have selected
click the a button for actions and
choose Zoom
it zooms in really close I'll zoom out
just a bit
now notice how parts of hemoglobin
appear chopped off this is because Zoom
applies clipping to the structure
clipping shaves away layers of the
molecule so that whatever you zoomed in
on can be seen easily adjust the
clipping by running two fingers up or
down on the track pad clipping can also
be adjusted using the drop down display
menu
let's rotate the molecule a bit by
clicking and dragging we can see that
the carbon monoxide binds near the hemin
hemoglobin carbon monoxide binds well to
hemoglobin and can prevent oxygen
binding this is the basis for carbon
monoxide poisoning and that's today's
lesson join me next time to learn how to
save selections and use them to display
different parts of the structure in
different ways thanks for watching